what if you called up we've got ten more
elegant in the Scottish way hi hello
Jessica Chastain and James McAvoy and
this is Eddie I'm abroad and I'm
American and he's Scottish
get ready John Hancock can you can you
give me some context let me see your
John Hancock there's an obvious woman is
it is it your handshake
hey that's close is it your signature
yes tops off that sack so that sounds
like off is it like let's party or let's
go it basically means like sun's out
guns out but for Scottish people they
move the first sign of sunlight which we
don't get a lot of every as quickly as
possible
my only lost 15 money's get boom I got
to first second third baseline
is it first base is kissing second base
is feelsies up the wave and then racing
waist Phillies up the way feels ease up
the ways up the waist of the ways okay
and then third bases feels he's doing
the Wiis didn't do Louise anyways while
you actually gave us more information
that we needed the meaning is it's the
bases are used to explain the stages of
sexual relationship and MacAvoy just
explain them on doing my tango finger
sounds like a penis but I know it's not
because I've never seen dango I'd never
see your doing the tango doing my dinger
I'd see all the things you're doing he
didn't do my
and in my heat well I thought it wasn't
doing my cleaning my penis no you're
fighting for me no you are really
annoying me see I don't know that cuz
James never said it to me because I
don't annoy him
oh this sudden like this one putting
lipstick on a pig I have good new ideas
oh is that like just saying you're
dressing up something better good luck
do what do they call that we've got time
for that don't we
more elegant in the Scottish way I've
got an American one for you and you pass
tonight
customer Jean Jean any Americans here
know what he's talking about
a man can join no I don't think jwn I've
heard that's my jam Billie Jean can be
many many things they can it means
things maybe that's the Delphine's of
the world please help live Bible and
back me up
that is yawn as a thing I'll take my
burger animal-style
oh that is means onions and that gives
me the bulk the bulk in the book oh my
god that the sight of you trying to
polish that little turd gives me double
Vicki me jeebies what's the
heebie-jeebies no embarrass no the bulk
is actually I think Bolton is actually
when you puke but the dry bulk is even
better when you see that that gives me
the dry book it's just your even your
that's the dry ball that's but he's he
says that's actually disgusting I just
[Applause]
only use my certain sites
oh really [ __ ] cool one
[Music]